hello and welcome to this video playing
ancient from South Africa at least it's
a South African flag and so and tomorrow
yep I guess okay never know we might
play c3 or something delayed Smith [ __ ]
okay well I take you on 26 years not
very common okay I want to try something
something interesting here with h5 rise
playing this very quickly hmm how do I
want to play age for or not mmhmm yeah
let's do this so that i can go to a 7
case of a night move I ok this is an
interesting interesting way of playing
494 so I'm going to do this this is all
very loose but wanted to try something
sunshine thing of BTM yeah well I could
add 5 on d5 I wonder i can actually go
back it's not i can go here I mean why
not my king position is shaky but it's
not that easy and this position hmm what
is he doing here I go t5 I don't quite
get it
d 59 f 627 that it's not good for him
maybe you can go Bishop h5 maybe now but
that's also not working Bishop h5 de
Foix check Quincy for Queen age 70
should win material
hmm okay so what is he doing now
yeah very wacky play by me but maybe
it's not that easy to refute yeah I
thought deform just win now why isn't it
I don't know made on h2 we cannot move
the bishop
j yeah to c7 I guess he hung up in my
ass some checks but I mean something
like it's a queen g6 Queen h5 Queen g7
check as possible but I don't think it
leads to that much yeah I'm so Queen h5
huh what is the point is that point you
should have four check I can I can do
this if I like just preventing that from
the get-go you still cannot move this
Bishop
just prevent we should have form in the
first place okay Bishop a 5-4 huh well I
can still take age 59 I don't really see
why not let's take it
check yeah so I'm also threatening and
made on age too so
so here I am see threatening anything
but should be three maybe I mean not
really a big thread or anything but hmm
let's just check if I've got something
simpler that I can do we should have
five check now come on don't be too
sophisticated him
internal nice little ideas Bishop e3
check king a6 knows not doing it what is
the point bishop is 30
it should be 3m
yeah maybe just this I guess
and I didn't even think of that what is
the idea I can always go to A six right
don't get it what is the point it just
has one check that's what I'm not quite
getting I mean probably there wasn't
anything anyway but Chad thought this is
rather simple white resigns yeah I was
probably just not a good good idea for
me that that all thinking about well
it's probably not super easy to play ok
Wendy five and I went the f5 yeah it's
that looks very known here and now yeah
I mean it cannot be good for me really
it cannot be but it it's not easy
certainly check this is already
condemned by the engine saying that
white is spoiling his advantage h3 is
supposed to be better which does not
threaten to take the night because of
the H file but probably it will it
threatens to threaten something like
that engine gives Bishop gives d5 or
Bishop e7 like 85 yeah there's this and
why does better yeah it's it's still
very very sharp but i believe i mean now
certainly willing to believe that it is
good good for why'd he abruptly to a
strong ya know ti ad5 is so interesting
Oh engine says Knight f6 is playable
okay okay I I didn't
too late deep enough and while he also
didn't know he played this but he can
take yeah i saw Queenie seven but i did
not see f5 and after f5 he has this
resource which will will kill me really
very strong yeah I strong okay this I
took this is a mistake average huge
losses after Queen age seven this is
betcha checking first yeah yeah of
course of course is better now I have to
do this King takes and now I don't have
Queen age seven this is given a slightly
better for white by the comp which is
saying always be area got a completely
wacky position and the assessment is
slightly better for someone I tough to
talk to corn but here I'm Charlie really
just winning without any further doom
tea eggs yeah Bishop f5 was a bit
stronger check yeah the engine actually
wants to take I wasn't totally sure
about this him but I can go hear him and
then to a six I didn't see this one yeah
I can go here and then sorry then then
to a six in case of a check now but this
wins as well o Queen age three was made
check check sure check check check mate
it's nice it would have been nice to
just to have seen that but I didn't
anyway I think it was an interesting
entertaining game thanks for watching